David beg no spent 17 days in Puerto
Rico covering Hurricane Maria he's
returned about half a dozen times since
then his tireless coverage earned him
praise from the citizens of Puerto Rico
and the prestigious George Polk award
for public service David beg know is now
in Wrightsville Beach North Carolina
right now covering hurricane Florence
he's had some experience at this David
you've learned some new information I'm
told about supplies that were sent to
Puerto Rico after the hurricane what can
you tell us about that gale this is
staggering the Federal Emergency
Management Agency has told CBS News that
what could be millions of bottles of
water that were sent to the island to
help their survivors of Hurricane maria
has been sitting on a runway in sabor
Puerto Rico since last year the pictures
are unbelievable to look at they were
taken with a man who works for the State
Police Agency there who told me David
I'm angry that they're still sitting
there and have been since last October
when he first saw them now here this is
important
FEMA says they gave the bottles of water
to the government of Puerto Rico the
question is what happened then why was
there a failure of distribution Gail
look you heard people in Puerto Rico
saying we're not getting enough water
and FEMA kept saying we're putting it
out there they see so much water sitting
on that runway that was never used and
now cannot be used we continue to follow
the story Gail we'll keep you posted
all right David Berg no thank you very
much